merci isabelle mes chers amis vous êtes
venus de toute la france de toutes nos
fédérations
vous incarnez la force le dynamisme de
ce mouvement qui derrière nicolas
sarkozy a pour vocation de préparer et
de conduire l'alternance dont notre pays
a tant besoin
vous incarnez ce parlement qui
représente nos militants être militant
c'est un engagement qui appelle à la
reconnaissance c'est un engagement qui
est noble c'est un engagement qui donne
de la force qui se bat qui se base sur
nos idées sur des convictions sur des
valeurs
certains regardent les militants avec
une forme de mépris
il ne faudrait pas les écouter il
faudrait les réunir mais jamais les
entendre et bien ce parlement du
mouvement ce conseil national incarne au
contraire la force et la pertinence de
ce message des militants les militants
de notre famille politique en constitue
le dynamisme la richesse il incarne cet
avenir que nous sommes en train de
construire ensemble derrière nicolas
sarkozy alors ce conseil national venu
de nos fédérations constitue la dernière
étape du renouveau et du redressement de
notre famille politique
après les épreuves qu'elle a subi nous
avons eu l'opportunité et le bonheur
délire
nicolas sarkozy à la fin de l'année 2014
dans un contexte de redressement et de
renouveau à la tête de notre famille
politique nous avons réformé nos statuts
nous avons réuni le congrès nous avons
donné un nouveau nom à notre famille
politique
les républicains et il restait à
mettre en ordre de marche nos
fédérations cela a été fait lors du
dernier week end de janvier avec
l'élection de plus de onze mille cadres
dans nos fédérations dans nos
départements auxquels je veux adresser
mes félicitations
ces élections que nous n'avions plus été
capable d'organiser depuis 2010 signe
des difficultés des faiblesses se sont
déroulé parfaitement dans la
transparence dans la démocratie et je
veux le dire dans l'unité et dans le
rassemblement
merci à tous ceux qui ont été les
acteurs de cette démocratie vivante
forte et pertinente
nous avons le 30 et 31 janvier
élu onze mille cadres je le disais 660
conseillers nationaux johann est élu
pour la première fois dans le cadre
départemental nous avons vous avez élu
102 présidents de fédérations et pour la
première fois ces présidents de
fédérations ont été élus au suffrage
direct par tous les militants
ce choix c'est nicolas sarkozy qui l'a
voulu
certains exprimé des inquiétudes est ce
que cette élection directe n'allait pas
être source de difficultés de tension et
bien non la concurrence
le débat la compétition ne sont jamais
source de difficultés lorsqu'au bout on
sait qu'il ya l'unité et le
rassemblement de la famille merci
d'avoir fait ce soir de l'élection
démocratique qui a donné de la vigueur à
notre famille politique
et puis ces élections ont été aussi le
cadre le moment d'un profond
renouvellement tout à l'heure
cela a été exprimé par nos candidats à
au conseil national à la présidence 50%
des nouveaux des présidents de
fédérations sont des nouveaux présidents
signe là aussi du renouvellement et du
renouveau alors oui grâce à ces
élections internes grâce à la réunion de
ce conseil national grâce à la dynamique
qui est impulsé notre parti est le
premier parti de france en terme de
militants deux cent quarante mille
militants à la fin de l'année 2015
c'est une force qui est en marche c'est
une force organisée
c'est une force qui va préparer
l'alternance sur un projet clair sur un
projet ambitieux sur un projet qui a de
l'audace sur un projet qui souligne la
force des valeurs de droite dans notre
pays
c'est ce projet dont nous allons
débattre aujourd'hui mais d'ores et déjà
notre parti est en ordre de marche est
organisée dans ses fédérations comme au
centre national merci de votre
engagement de votre mobilisation et
sachets compter sur la disponibilité de
la direction des fédérations de tous
ceux qui autour de nicolas sarkozy
assure le relais avec nos fédérations et
nos militants